[Music]
so last week we covered binga's
relationship problems and today we're
covering an NBA players's baby mama who
is very famous in America because she's
got all these Instagram followers come
she posts pictures of her book and she
went on a podcast and talked about
finding true love the problem is she
also talked about her body count how
many men she slept within a day and it's
gone viral so let's watch the video and
see if we think she's got a chance of
finding true love you with with one man
two men 3 men four men over the course
of a 24hour 48 hour SP did you think
about the ramifications of how people
men women everybody would look at you
there was a video that I did in my car
where I was talking about how I had sex
with was it three men in a a day and
then I ended up getting a yeast
infection that was I came out pretty
unscathed well that's good then was just
a East infection what were you worried
about it's like she's just happy it's
not AIDS I get like AIDS is is is is
pretty bad so they tell me I've never
had it but you shouldn't be chuffed
that's all I'm saying no judgment but
just think of the health what happens
when you're on the way driving to the
third guy's house I'm assuming you've
been [__] in a couple of times now and
the sort of the novelty should be Weare
enough what about the first two guys
like what was not enough about them like
you needed a third how many inches does
a woman need in a 24-hour period that is
the real question here what is the
average penis size wait there we need to
find this out first time I've ever
searched this just to be clear penis
size Oh by country well we could even
narrow it down to America assuming she
was in America erect 5 in makes me feel
better so just on an average she would
have had a minimum of 15 in in that
period if they were above average we
could be looking at 20 plus so that's a
lot we'll leave that search open just in
case we need to come back I was on birth
control for 10 I'm trying to let her
talk but imagine you're the third Geer
and like what you going down on her like
that's that is raw in it these are the
dark thoughts but it's her fault for
putting them you open our legs and it oh
it's all what's been going on here
Goldie looks over here come Bez this
wasn't my intention when I sat down I
promise you this is about relationships
we're being serious here and I got off
of it because there was a conversation
with my child's father okay so I I again
the whole trapping thing can't drop the
Willing babe you never wanted a baby
daddy you wanted to be a mom he's saying
she wanted to be a mom but like why are
you [__] three guys in a day if
that's the goal you just play in the
National Lottery it could be anyone so
long I had my baby when I was 29 I
thought I was doing it right I thought
that was my guy and I and I never really
liked kids I always thought I referred
to them as crotch goblins lovely woman I
don't know why women like this have
children you know but as I got older I
wanted one as I got older and I met an
NBA player who was on 17 million pound a
year I thought maybe we'll have a child
just to be clear she is rumored to be on
$200,000 a month child maintenance just
spitballing might have had something to
do with it but did you think I think
about the ramifications of telling
people that I had sex with multiple men
yes I don't care it's the truth if you
don't if you don't see me as a potential
dating person then great one less heart
to break leave me alone and I'm going to
continue to live my trth but you do
understand Britney that's hard for man
look like you said public versus private
now if you and I having a conversation
and we're you're sitting up here we have
a conversation and you say well Shana I
slept with this many men okay that's one
thing that's between you and I but to
have that conversation and then
everybody Sam John and everybody else
knows it that's a whole different that's
a whole
different I love this guy that's fine
with me I mean I feel that but see
that's selfish because all you're
thinking about is
you yeah no he's got other come on he
has the privilege to be with me okay
because you know how many women you've
slept with BR that's you know how many
women you slept with doesn't matter
though does it unfortunately cuz women
don't care how many women a man has had
men do care so therefore your argument
is irrelevant before everyone starts
complaining oh double standards yes
double standards that's life that's what
other the people say that's how it is I
don't make the rules I'm just relaying
them don't shoot the messenger yes or no
I'm doing the inter do you know don't
like it when people do that during the
talking [__] annoying how many women
you yes double digits triple digits here
we go s back in this position this is
her technique that she uses which is I
feel threatened I feel defensive
therefore flip it on the guy cuz we're
not then scrutinizing what she's been
doing that Old Chestnut it probably
works on stupid men you love what you
love it's a a high bar to hurdle if she
makes things that she's
done public the truth of the matter is
is most men within reason won't really
care how many you know men or woman has
been with to a degree providing the
whole [__] world doesn't know about
it and the the thing he's bringing up is
why did you feel the need to tell
everyone because you've just cockblocked
yourself to a certain group of men why
because men look at women is an
extension of their personal value that
they bring when they walk into a room
with their woman they want to have the
respect of everyone for their woman for
their relationship and to feel like
they're not the 501st guy even if they
are the 501st guy they just don't want
everyone [__] knowing that they want
to feel like what they've got is
somewhat special and how can it be
special when they're the 51st one and
when you've been doing three in one day
not very special is it I me the only
thing I can think of off the top of my
head that's special a three in one day
is like Christmas dinner you know like
start a man and pudding that's special
she's no Christmas dinner I believe that
the average person is below average that
makes sense the average guy would tell
you that I'm not wife material that's
fine because I don't want to be with the
average man the man that I want is
someone who is understanding of that and
if that's asking for too much from the
male species then I I must be better off
alone okay so apparently average men
don't find her to be wife material but
that's okay cuz she doesn't want an
average man anyway she wants above
average clearly above average men want a
woman that average men wish they could
have so if average men don't want you
then why the hell would an above average
man want you when she says average men
aren't understanding to who she is well
average men should be more understanding
than above average men above average men
have more desirability therefore they
can be less understanding to your
[__] she really isn't thinking this
through is she part of the problem for
her was going to be when you're getting
200 Grand a month off of an NBA player
men don't want to be in that scenario
because for a start that man is
providing you with a [__] load of money
so immediately he's going to feel cooked
by the fact of this guy has Financial
power to put a roof over your head and
therefore you're being provided for by
another man so how's a man going to be
able to have a say in a relationship
when you're able to turn around and go I
get my bills paid by another man you can
shut the [__] up this would be a
nightmare scenario for most men actually
the average person is not going to want
to make that make that jump and that's
okay cuz I'm not talking to them I don't
need anybody average I'm not average
there's nothing about my mentality
that's average I don't carry myself as
average I don't look average I'm not
mundane and forgettable just like these
other not like these other [__] it's
pretty clear that she's not a fan of
average people this is the sort of
entitlement that comes with getting 200
Grand in your bank account every month
just cuz you fought some guy and she's
like I'm memorable yeah you're memorable
for all the wrong reasons you're
annoying because there's this little box
and people want me to just like like
suck shut up make an only fans let me
finish though they want me to go over
here and just admit that I'm a gold
digger you don't need to make an only
fans you're getting 200 Grand a month
from a fell who you had a baby with so
I'm better than only fans thing believe
me if that guy wasn't delivering the
check every month she'd be on only fanss
trap guys and that I only care about
money but because I go so hard about
true love it's a mother problem women
who do this can you stop please it's
really [__] annoying but you can
understand that you say because I like
sex like you we just need to calm down
this is an interview love come on chill
because I like sex I like cheeseburgers
but if I had three in a day that's more
than liking it am I right I'm not saying
she's a [__] but I'm not saying she's
not a [__] what am I selling well I mean
when you go on and you in your car and
you say well I had sex with three men
that was back in 2018 by the
way can we just stop with a judging
right that happened in 2018 okay no
woman can outrun their past because all
it does it makes you tired when it
catches up with you so what you did in
2018 people still know about it in 2023
do you know things that happened a few
years ago people still remember imagine
having to explain that to someone that's
where we're at in this this interview
right now people have what they call the
internet people have what they call
memory good don't ever forget it just
know when you tried this yeah did you
hear what she just said do you know when
you try this a lot of people have tried
it no one seems to have bought it that's
the tragedy I don't believe you can
delete your Hess I don't want to this is
like when you're watching like a teenage
girl like I didn't want to anyway of
course you did you're freaking out right
now in the middle of an interview rather
than just being C out and saying yeah
feel a bit crap about it she's acting
like a lunatic I would not want a clean
slate today because you know why this
whole journey for me has been learning
she's been on a Learning Journey she's
learned a lot I'm judged for the way
that I learned then so be it have you
seen how she just made her the victim if
I'm judged by the way that I learned
we're talking about her doing three
dicks in a day not [__] giving too
much to charity I don't need a guy
that's going to keep my record of wrongs
I thought that's what the Bible says
what the [__] we're going into the Bible
now that's when you know you're
searching just any forgiveness Bible
don't fault me for doing the best I
could with the awareness I had I like
that line I'm using that one in future
if someone pulls me up on anything I've
done I'm going to say I did the best I
could with the awareness I had it makes
you wonder like what was the awareness
did no one say probably should just keep
it a two dicks a day what she is doing
is like placing blame on other people
like I wasn't I wasn't taught the right
way she's deflecting a lot who God
creator Source Universe whatever you
want to call it who God designed for me
none of that matters when there's a
woman who is dysfunctional who was very
very difficult very masculine and
aggressive and she can't find a man to
put up with her [__] the one thing they
always come down to is they go God has
got a man out there for me and when I
meet him he's going to put up with
everything that I bring to the table and
he's going to love me anyway it's the
thing they all say and trust me it's
[__] men are quite similar we have
similar levels of Tolerance of [__] we
can be bothered with and someone who
claps as they talk at you and is more
aggressive than a man and Fs more men
than men [__] women that's more of a man
than we are we don't want to have have a
relationship with a man we want peace we
want calm we want femininity we want
gentle energy and those women out there
who bring that you won't have to think
of a man magically appearing out of
nowhere to put up with your [__] because
you'll already have a man guaranteed
that's the way men are we gravitate
towards femininity I don't care about
all these people yapping about what I'm
not going to get do you know when I
don't care about something I don't go do
you know I don't care about all these
people yapping that's not how I behave
when I don't care about something it's
so delusional it's [__] crazy I don't
care yeah you're so aloof right now
because if I wasn't going to get it it
wouldn't be on my heart if I wasn't
going to get it I would not have been I
would not be experiencing the dark side
of this
coin she said if I wasn't going to end
up falling in love with a man I wouldn't
be experiencing this shitty loneliness
right now this is how people avoid the
message from the universe which is
you're not getting what you want because
you need to do some work on yourself you
need to change you need to grow and you
need to become someone who was more
appealing to the opposite sex because
right now everything you're sending out
is giving out nothing back he has the
problem for her she could get a man but
it ain't the type of man she wants the
man she wants would never put up with
that [__] so she's probably going to end
up with a man who's subservient to her
and takes all of her crap and she
doesn't like him for that reason she'll
she'll actually inside find him annoying
because he doesn't stand up to her and
he doesn't put her in her place cuz
that's what she actually wants but men
who can have the pick of all those women
they don't want to have to put a woman
in their place they want a woman who's
ready made for the job who's going to be
easygoing chill accommodating gentle
agreeable they don't want to argue with
someone who's clapping at you like this
and I know there's a lot of women who
watches this channel I Pro I promise you
if you listen to what I'm saying you
can't go wrong I don't know how I'm
Haven explained this but there's a lot
of women out there like this right now
who are in delusional land and she
probably thinks oh well I meet that when
I meet that guy then I'll be like that
no chance no chance you are who you are
and you will continue to behave like
that no matter who the comes into your
life this is just her in a in an
interview where she should be at her
best and that's why the world will bear
witness to true love I'm sure it will
I'm going to tell the truth and still
get everything I want and they're going
to watch me you see this stamping of the
feet and I'm going to get everything I
want that's exactly why you're not
because she's quoting the universe well
the universe is a very funny way of
working and it teaches you lessons and
people with this stubborn attitude of I
want it all my way and everything's
going to be exactly how I want it that's
exactly why you won't get that she's
unreasonable and when you're
unreasonable good people don't want the
[__] thing to do with you and after
everything she says she's been through
here she's shown that she hasn't learned
anything because when he said do you
regret it she says no and it's like well
you you've learned nothing then have you
and if you can't learn from your
mistakes then how can you overcome this
attitude to evolve into the kind of
person that a good man is going to want
to be with you have no chance and the
irony is is now this is out there she's
going to deter even more men because
they're all going to see this cuz men
watch Shannon sharp in America so even
now they're going to watch this and go
[__] that I don't have to play by your
guys' rules I do my way okay some
point you do things your way he's in or
of our isn't he he's like what a [__]
idiot and honestly it varies hour to
hour I didn't know who I was going to be
when I came into this interview I'm
starting to think that the problem is a
bit deeper than uh being difficult to be
in a relationship with I think we need
therapy if I'm being honest are you okay
with the way it's played out thus far
absolutely I'm at peace with it there's
nothing I could have done differently
literally not true there's just no
accountability but and what's great
about this interview is a lot of these
negative traits we're saying from her
are encapsulated by so many thousands of
people on social media right now and
thinking I can just do whatever the [__]
I want and someone out there will have
to put up with it it's mental oh they
you could have done differently stop
saying that there's nothing you could
have done differently stop it this is
the way I was meant to do
it I don't question fate I don't
question I accept my fate I accept my
destiny whenever she gets backed into a
corner it's about God and about God
providing a man who will put up with
this and now it's about well this was
all fate and I was supposed to do three
dicks in a day so it all happened the
way it was meant to accountability is
just non-existent that means that it
takes me 10 years for my Mr Wonderful to
come then that's fine she's 31 now so
she still got that like that youth so
that she can delude herself into
thinking well if it takes another 10
years it does the universe will beat
this out of her in a cruel way and it'll
be the hard pill to swallow later on in
life when she realizes I had so much
attention and so many people around me
who wanted to be with me but I was such
a toxic person that I pushed everyone
away it's sad actually because she is
pretty and I'm sure she can get men's
attention but she doesn't know what the
[__] to do with it cuz she's such a man
herself you would change a thing about
the way it's transpired yeah for what
cuz if here's the thing about regret if
I regret things that happened then that
means I have to erase the awareness that
I gained she doesn't want to regret you
know why she doesn't want to regret cuz
she doesn't want to face up to the
negative things that she's done to
people in the past and actually have to
look within herself and realize I was a
pretty crappy person then cuz that's
going to make her feel bad and people
like her they don't operate with guilt
like the way she conducted this whole
interview was like [__] everyone I'm
doing it my way I only care about myself
so guilt isn't even on the radar for her
when I started watching this I had no
idea it was going to be this toxic I'm
just supposed to be some Instagram
thought but here I am talking to shanon
shark so you you got to listen to me so
you grade at what you do I certainly am
you listen to her cuz she's a car Crush
basically I think this is a great
example of the shortsightedness we've
got in society right now with people who
just want money now Fame now and [__]
the long term but in the long term
that's that's not going to make her
happy you can tell she's not happy what
she really wants is someone to love her
and to have a family and all of that but
she doesn't conduct herself like a woman
who'd have that sort of stuff and she's
not looking at people who have that
thinking should I be more like them
she's like [__] them I'm going to keep
being the way I am and it'll happen no
matter what if you want a certain kind
of partner you have to think about what
they want in a in a in a woman for
example if you're a woman out there I
don't think any man wants a woman like
her if I'm being honest but the kind of
men she wants definitely don't want a
woman like this and just because one had
sex with her that doesn't count she
wants the marriage the kids she wants it
all you can get one to stick your dick
in you but you ain't going to get more
than that not behaving like this and I
think one of the main takeaways from
this is just the level of selfishness
that she has is wild if you want a
relationship full stop with anyone being
that selfish makes it impossible but
luckily she's not our problem let me
know what you thought in the comments
below hit the like button don't forget
to subscribe to the true Jordy YouTube
channel before any of you go oh he's
such a misogynist now it's about time
someone call this crap out because she
is literally giving out advice to a
whole generation of young women and the
last thing we need is to anyone to
listen to that don't forget to hit that
like button stay subscribed to the true
Jordy YouTube channel thanks for
watching and I'll see you
later